Let's look at the solution to this part of
our BTB & BHT quiz. The question now is, which
of the four BTB entries do we use for each
of these instructions? Leave the field blank if none is
used. We already know that we use the BTB
once here and a hundred times here, and that's all
of the BTB uses. So the only instructions that we
really need to put something for is this and this.
How do we determine which BTB entry do we use? Well, we look at the address and
just the same way that we did it for the BHT, in this case, the address is
C008. The BTB has four entries. We take
the lower most two bits, in this case, because
we need two bits to tell us which of
the four entries. But, we don't use the bits
that are always the same for all instructions. In this case, the lower most
two bits. So, really, this is the number of the BTB entry for the C008
instruction. 10 is 2. So we will use the entry number 2. The other instruction
that we need to figure out is at the address C01C. So it's going to
be C01C. Again, ignore the lower most bits that
stay the same. Take the next two bits because
we need to know which of the four entries
to use, and we get 11, which corresponds to
the entry number 3. As you can see, only entries number 2 and 3 are used in this
loop. If this instruction were a taken branch, it
would have used and entry number 0. This one would
have used 1, 2, 3, and then, because
we have 4 entries, this one, again, would be
using entry number 0, 1, 2, 3. But
because these are the only ones that actually use
these entries, all we have to do is
access the entry number 2 here. It's accessed once,
if you remember. And access the entry number 3
here. It's accessed a hundred times, if you remember.